bonsoir
[Musique]
le changement tout le monde connaît le
changement il est quotidien pour moi il
a été
radical parce que il y a il y a quelques
années ma vie c'était ça c'était la
montagne c'était le sport c'était la
mère
je viens de Perpignan donc pas très loin
d'ici et puis un jour tout a changé dans
ma vie et un changement si brutal que
j'ai compris que plus rien ne serait
jamais comme avant j'ai compris j'ai
compris que j'avais le il y a deux choix
il y a le choix donc c'est soit
tu fuis
ta limite tu as envie de te en
l'air parce que ce qu'il est en train de
se passer c'est dramatique
gravissime soit tu te dis ben je vais
m'adapter à ce qu'il est en train de se
passer je vais aller de l'avant même
sous le coup de la colère je vais
avancer mais à cette époque là sous le
choc j'ai absolument pas envie de ça je
suis à des années lumières de me dire je
vais m'adapter à ce changement
j'ai eu des idées super sombres les
pires idées alors que ma vie d'avant ce
changement ma vie d'avant c'était ça
j'ai connu mes premiers championnats du
monde j'avais 12 ans j'ai grandi dans
une famille de sportifs de sportif pas
forcément de sportif de niveau mais de
sportifs qui m'ont inculqué des valeurs
qui m'ont inculqué une éducation qui
m'ont inculqué le goût de l'effort donc
du coup j'ai participé à mes premiers
championnats du monde j'avais 12 ans
j'ai fait une carrière dans le BMX
international pendant 10 ans puis après
j'en ai eu marre j'ai j'ai basculé sur
le sport d'hiver puisque j'habite pas
loin de la montagne
et puis
ce changement il a tout changé
brutalement un matin au réveil un matin
d'octobre 2002
j'entends une sonnerie dans mon
appartement
machinalement on est un lundi matin je
m'étais octroyer une petite matinée de
répit je tape sur mon réveil je me rends
compte que c'est pas le réveil que c'est
le téléphone dans la maison et puis là
je cherche je jette ma couette je pose
mes jambes sur le sol et là mes jambes
sur des robes sous mon poids
je me retrouve cloué par terre
je comprends pas je m'accroche au
matelas j'essaie de me relever à nouveau
et je reste cloué par terre
on va me transporter aux urgences de
l'hôpital de Perpignan et au bout de
quatre jours
ce changement radical va débarquer dans
ma chambre d'hôpital il va être
il va porter le nom il va porter le nom
de sclérose en plaques de 17 lettres de
la sclérose en plaques c'est une maladie
grave et dégénérative du système nerveux
central qui empêche le corps de
fonctionner correctement
de là je bascule alors moi la sportive
ou l'exportive moi la girl power la
jeune femme indépendante qui voulait
réussir sa vie qui voulait pas d'enfant
qui voulait pas de relation stable tout
ça je me retrouve à basculer dans ce
changement
du handicap je me retrouve du jour au
lendemain avec un score solide pourtant
un score docile qui a l'habitude de
participer à des heures et des heures à
des heures d'entraînement qui a
l'habitude de se relever de l'échec
d'une compétition qui a l'habitude de
s'adapter à la difficulté du terrain le
sport à odeur pour le coup le BMX Souls
snowboard c'est par excellence des
sports d'adaptation tu n'adaptes à la
météo tu t'adaptes au terrain donc du
coup je me retrouve là à me dire mais
qu'est-ce que je vais faire de ça
la première des questions que je pose
neurologue c'est est-ce que je vais
remarcher
il me répond pas je lui crie dessus je
lui dis mais ce que je vais remarcher
il m'a dit je ne sais pas il me dit la
maladie elle a frappé tellement fort
d'entrée que il se peut que vous ne
remariez jamais mais on sait pas c'est
une épée Damoclès un point
d'interrogation c'est tout ça il me dit
mais par contre des premiers mots qu'il
est qu'il a pu me dire il va falloir
s'adapter s'adapter il va falloir vivre
avec non pas vivre avec pas du tout
vivre avec il va falloir vivre malgré le
handicap malgré la maladie c'est pas du
tout dans mes perspectives de vie c'est
pas du tout dans les perspectives
d'objectif j'ai pas j'ai pas fait des
études j'ai pas fait du sport j'ai pas
fait des sacrifices de vie de jeune
adulte d'adolescent j'ai pas fait pour
vivre ça pour vivre le handicap pour
vivre l'incertitude d'un jour au marché
un jour et du coup cette chute ce
changement il a
il a duré quand même j'ai passé de
nombreuses mais vraiment c'est du jour
au lendemain du jour au lendemain j'ai
quand j'ai attendu ce diagnostic que je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'il soit aussi
pire aussi grave j'ai passé 4 jours sur
mon lit d'hôpital à ne pas comprendre
pourquoi mes jambes ne fonctionnaient
plus j'ai pas c'est 4 jours à me
lassérer les jambes à me mettre des
coups de fourchette dans les jambes pour
essayer de ressentir une quelconque
sensation avec ma brosse à cheveux à me
mettre à me lacérer les jambes pour
essayer de retrouver
rien une toute petite sensation mais en
tout cas essaie de comprendre pourquoi
et quand mes jambes aller reboucher
et puis en fait mon adaptation ça a été
quoi ça a été je me suis pas je me suis
adapté au rythme des autres je me suis
adapté à un rythme depuis tout à je me
suis cette semaine d'hôpital 16 mois
sans de rééducation je me suis adapté au
fait d'appuyer d'appuyer sur un bouton
pour aller aux toilettes d'appuyer sur
un bouton pour manger d'appuyer sur un
bouton pour être lavé d'appuyer sur un
bouton pour qu'on réponde à des
questions et j'avais pas envie de ça
j'avais pas envie de ça et puis la vie
elle est
en main on m'a élevé en me disant que
derrière des problèmes se cachent des
opportunités que les choses dans la vie
arrivent
pas par hasard elles arrivent souvent
pour une bonne raison et puis j'ai fait
des rencontres à ma vie qui ont fait
qu'à un moment il y a quelqu'un qui m'a
aidé à retrouver l'espoir à retrouver
l'envie de vivre tout simplement l'envie
de vivre malgré cette maladie malgré cet
handicap et il a vu en moi le potentiel
dans mes ressources de ce que j'avais
fait comme sport dans mon éducation
d'avancer et de m'adapter
à cette vie parce que quoi qu'il en soit
de vie on en a qu'une et quoi qu'il en
soit cette vie j'avais envie de la vivre
de m'adapter à cette maladie de
m'adapter à des gens douloureuses de
m'adapter à un périmètre de marge parce
qu'après ce kiné m'a fait sortir de mon
fauteuil roulant de m'adapter un
périmètre de marche hyper réduit de
m'adapter à à une vue défaillante de
m'adapter à des troubles cognitifs de ma
data des troubles
urinaires des troubles intimes de façon
est-ce que j'avais le choix j'avais plus
le choix parce que j'avais décidé de
vivre j'avais décidé de vivre par contre
il a fallu faire des deuils
le deuil selon les médecins à l'époque
il a fallu faire le deuil du sport donc
ça c'était quelque chose de vraiment
vraiment dramatique pour moi de faire le
deuil du sport et puis finalement
je me suis reconstruit différemment je
me suis j'ai voulu en fait coucher sur
le papier ce que j'avais vécu ce que
j'étais en train de vivre ça a été mon
exutoire ça a été mon écriture
thérapeutique un livre puis un autre
puis finalement
la vie le handicap a fait complètement
changé ma philosophie de fille grâce à
cette rencontre grâce à ce kiné qui a vu
en moi toujours cette petite cette
petite fille cette petite adolescente en
moi qui sommeil en moi et qui voulait
aller retrouver le côté sportif la gagne
alors par contre la gagne pas sur le
terrain du sport à l'époque mais en tout
cas la gagne différemment donc ça a été
des projets je me suis fixé déjà
objectif l'écriture et puis après je me
suis dit ok arrête
arrête de crier à l'injustice de la vie
c'est bon on va pas refaire l'histoire
ce qui est passé est passé arrête de
dire pourquoi pourquoi parce que je l'ai
eu dur mais vraiment très dur quand on
bascule du jour au lendemain d'une vie
de rêve au cauchemar tu l'as forcément
dur et puis
je me suis dit ok tu es une personne
handicapée tu as décidé de vivre et de
vivre à fond donc maintenant ok on
arrête de dire ton pourquoi maintenant
pourquoi ok tu es une personne
handicapée mais qu'est-ce que tu en fais
comment tu avances avec ça comment tu
avances un essai de vivre le plus fort
possible le de manière le plus la plus
passionnée possible comment tu avances
et du coup je me suis dit
et si le handicap était une opportunité
et si j'adapté ma vie à cette
opportunité c'est dur c'est bizarre de
dire ça que le handicap peut être une
chance une opportunité dans la vie et
pourtant ça l'a été ça l'a été parce que
j'ai décidé de surfer sur ce qu'on
appelle la discrimination positive
en 2005 il y a eu une loi qui est obligé
des entreprises de plus de 20 salariés à
embaucher des collaborateurs handicapés
et ben j'étais une personne handicapée
je l'ai surfé sur ses côtés surfer sur
cette discrimination positive et
j'allais devenir
j'allais devenir journaliste sportive en
remplissant les cases de la diversité
donc du coup j'ai
osé j'ai osé adapter réadapter mon CV à
cette ligne supplémentaire qui faisait
deux mois une personne handicapée avec
une
RQTH une reconnaissance de qualité de
travailleur handicapé et puis voilà ça
m'a permis de rentrer à la base par la
petite porte puis je suis devenu
rédactrice en chef au Figaro donc je
vivais le sport j'en avais fait le deuil
physiquement physiologiquement mais je
le vivais par procuration puisque
j'étais journaliste sportive et puis
je me suis retrouvé un événement sportif
et j'étais censée interviewer un sportif
qui partait faire les Jeux paralympiques
de Sotchi et là je vois un jeune homme
arriver Patrice amputé
et je lui dis je suis fascinée déjà je
suis fascinée par sa protège je suis
fascinée il tient un snowboard alors que
moi j'ai fait le deuil du snowboard et
c'est dur pour moi de me retrouver à la
montagne face à un snowboarder et je me
retrouve face à lui tout sourire super à
l'aise avec son snowboard avec sa
prothèse et tout et je lui explique ce
que je suis
que j'ai un handicap qui à cette époque
là je suis avec une canne parce que je
suis sorti de mon fauteuil grâce à ce
fabuleux kiné et je suis avec ma canne
et
ce Patrice je lui dis voilà je suis une
personne handicapée en handicap moi
visible que toi j'ai une sclérose en
plaques j'ai des difficultés avec mes
jambes avec mon équilibre et là il me
répond ah mais c'est super
attends est-ce qu'on a la même
définition du mot super cool et handicap
et là je lui dis en plus je viens des
Pyrénées mais c'est génial tu es une
personne handicapée des Pyrénées c'est
génial la levori il était mais il était
aux anges il avait il avait des étoiles
dans les yeux j'avais des papillons dans
le ventre parce que il me dit mais tu
sais quoi en équipe de France on cherche
des athlètes qui ont des handicaps pour
les préparer pour les jeux et et voilà
et on adaptera on adaptera on va parler
de ton handicap on va parler de tes
limites parce que le handicap c'est ça
c'est une imitation de notre activité
donc du coup on va parler de tes limites
on va adapter ton matériel on va adapter
ton rythme d'entraînement on va on va
tout comprendre donc c'était important
déjà de comprendre pour moi aussi de
comprendre ce qui se passait
sportivement dans mon corps mais là je
me suis dit mais alléluia je vais
pouvoir en adaptant ma pratique en
comprenant ce qui se passe en allant de
l'avant en ayant notre vie aussi je vais
pouvoir refaire du sport mais merci
Patrice et puis je le voyais il m'a tout
expliqué il avait développé sa prothèse
il avait bien il avait mis un petit un
petit amortisseur Fox dans son genou il
est incroyable adapté son rythme de vie
adapter sa maison adapter son rythme
professionnel il avait tout adapté il
m'a fait comprendre le chant des
possibles au-delà du handicap non pas
malgré le handicap mais avec le handicap
et du coup ben rapidement on a
rapidement quasiment le jour même il m'a
dit il m'a dit qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'il bug dans tes jambes donc je lui
dis écoute j'ai quand même même si ça se
voit pas autant que toi j'ai mon
handicap il y a 80 % et touche mon corps
il me dit est-ce que tu as de la force
dans les jambes bah non il y avait on a
causé pas on a coché pas mal de cases
non il me dit ben écoute tu as des
jambes plus fatigué plus faible on va
prendre une planche plus souple je dis
alors je bouge beaucoup parce que j'ai
des problèmes d'équipe si je reste
statique vous allez me voir tomber par
terre donc je lui dis je dis j'ai
tendance à tomber en arrière t'inquiète
pas on va adapter les plans on va
attaquer fixation de snowboard et les
boots snowboard on va mettre des petites
cale donc si j'arrive à faire tout le
temps vers l'avant il me dit je lui dis
je me fatigue vite donc un terme qui est
très propre à sclérose en plaques il me
dit c'est pas grave on s'entraînera plus
souvent mais moi longtemps
tout était possible c'est avec Patrice
tout était possible et tout est possible
et du coup eh ben effectivement ben ce
Patrice là il m'a
il m'a pendant trois jours à la montagne
j'étais censé faire un sujet sur lui
mais je l'ai fait hein on a plus fait un
sujet sur moi et du coup on a fait du
snowboard je suis tombée plein de fois
mais par contre pas comme quelques
années avant je suis tombée mais je me
suis relevé et du coup il m'a filmé il
avait une petite caméra il m'a filmé il
a il a transmis les les images au
directeur de la fédé puis elle est
entraîneur du groupe national et puis
j'étais contacté on s'est entraîné
non-stop non-stop
pour aller à pour dans l'objectif même
si c'était trois mois plus tard mais
pour lui pour lui tout était jouable et
tout était possible la fédé du coup a
demandé une autorisation exceptionnelle
pour que je puisse participer au Jeu de
Sotchi en 2014 qui arrivait trois mois
plus tard jour pour jour 14 mars ma
rencontre avec Patrice à 14 décembre 14
mars les Jeux paralympiques de Sotchi et
effectivement je me suis retrouvée assez
assez alors déjà à me réconcilier avec
ce corps parce que Julian est
terriblement voulu à la base c'est cool
c'est coup de fourchette c'est cool
c'était pas c'était pas pour me pour me
détruire c'était vraiment pour ressentir
une une quelconque sensation et puis il
y a eu cet acceptation cette acceptation
de mon corps je me suis enfin réconcilié
avec mon corps et il y a eu accepté de
montrer ce corps entier mais invisible
ce corps que les gens malheureusement en
stigmatise trop souvent le handicap par
le fauteuil roulant donc du coup je me
suis mise en petite tenue sportive qui
me représentait et je suis allé sur et
je suis allée sur me positionner et
montrer ce qu'on entier et puis je me
suis réconciliée avec ce corps et je me
suis surtout réconciliée avec le sport
j'ai remporté cette médaille d'argent à
ceci en 2014 mais après l'argent ça me
suffisait plus 4 ans plus tard je
remporte lors l'argent et le bronze ça
me suffisait pas ça me suffisait pas et
donc du coup par rapport à tout ce qui
était en train de se passer tout ce qui
s'est en train de passer ce process en
fait d'adaptation pour moi de comprendre
tout ce qui était je vivais à nouveau un
rêve un rêve au-delà des limites de
handicap au-delà avec tout ce qu'on
avait mis en place où ça a été le mot
d'ordre dans l'équipe de France de de
faire en sorte d'adapter mon rythme de
vie d'adapter ma performance d'adapter
mon matériel d'adapter en plus au
handicap qui était en train de gagner un
peu plus de terrain parce que
plus en avance plus j'avance dans la
mine dans ma maladie ben c'est un peu un
jour sans plus c'est une maladie
dégénérative plus le handicap se dégrade
et du coup ben en Italie la chercher on
est allé on est adapté on a compris on a
vécu avec cet handicap on a vécu cette
aventure sportive et cette médaille d'or
je suis allée la chercher et d'ailleurs
je vais aller la chercher parce qu'elle
est là aussi
[Applaudissements]
elle est là
ah non c'est bon j'ai assez pleuré il y
a 20 ans vous avez pas me faire pleurer
de nouveau mais bon mais bon voilà il y
a pas eu une photo sur le podium des
jeux il y en a une photo de moi en train
de sourire parce que j'ai énormément
pleuré donc voilà je suis encore je suis
encore très sensible à tout ça et du
coup vous connaissez c'est une boîte de
chocolat ça donc la vie ça peut être une
médaille d'or mais bon je dis souvent la
vie c'est un sport et le sport c'est la
vie mais j'ai envie de on va pas
terminer sur mes moments à moi on va
terminer sur les mots de Forrest Gump
que vous connaissez qui disait toujours
mais la vie c'est comme une boîte de
chocolat on sait jamais sur quoi on va
tomber donc quoi qu'il en soit quoi sur
quoi que vous puissiez tomber
adaptez-vous soyez heureux vivez fort
inventez vous et souriez voilà
[Applaudissements]